[Música]
boa noite eu sou o niqab ele porque eu
aprendi uma coisinha muito importante
com uma senhora chamada lei alguns ali
que a gente precisa falar o nome
sobrenome para que o racismo machismo
não coloque o nome que quiser
então por exemplo apresenta como niqab
ele e sobre o ponto é muito difícil a
gente pensar em colaboração quando não
entendemos as particularidade do outro e
eu tive que aprender isso da pior
maneira possível
infelizmente porque nenhuma criança os
seis anos que aprender algo dessa forma
e pra que vocês possam entender vamos
voltar um pouco no tempo e tentando
imaginar aquela questão de vir na minha
pele
eu criança negra é numa escola
particular
querendo fazer parte de diversos
grupinhos aquele grupo todo mundo faz
mesmo você tirando notas boas tendo
melhor com o comportamento da turma isso
não era suficiente para você ser inclusa
nesses grupos
e se você aumentar na verdade será alvo
de piadas
infelizmente todas as piadas que era
direcionado a mim
a professora as professoras é diziam que
era brincadeira né
então você volta pra casa uma criança de
67 anos volta para casa acreditando que
a professora falou então você vai não
munique é só uma brincadeira amanhã vai
ser melhor
amanhã você vai fazer parte do grupo e
não vai precisar ficar se matando para
tirar notas boas e tendo um melhor
comportamento para ser inclusa na sala
de aula
tá tudo bem
beleza tudo bem até aí e mais ou menos
não tão bem assim como a gente imagina
você vai pro ensino médio você cresce e
entende que todas as piadas e todas as
brincadeiras tinha outro nome
infelizmente
e esse nome é racismo
só que costumamos crescer entendendo que
racismo é bullying mas racismo éboli
racismo racismo racismo é crime
infelizmente e quando você chega no
ensino médio
você acha que as coisas
chorar e até que melhorou mesmo porque
você começa a fazer parte de grupos
nem que seja aquele grupo de estudo para
tentar passar no enem e fazer vestibular
mas pela primeira vez na minha vida
sempre parte de algo e que pena que foi
aos 16 anos mas que muita gente ainda
passa por essa situação muito mais velha
do que eu porque eu já tenho 21 e
pensando nessas questões e tentando já
nesses grupos
eu comecei atrás inquietações do meu
lugar de fahel enquanto mulher negra e
minhas vivências não tão boas
estava tudo bem até aí estava tudo lindo
até trazer essas questões e eu acho que
vocês sabem também que quando a gente
começa a fazer um debate focado em raça
e gênero lugar de fala você virar alvo
de uma coisa chamada vitimismo mimi
então o ensino médio foi muito por aí
só que eu tava querendo opinar eu sempre
tinha idéias para sugerir e de tanto ser
silenciada tanto de tanto ser
interrompida a cada fala eu comecei
retrair por que essa reação que a gente
tem inicialmente infelizmente a vacina
faz isso com a gente então começou a
retrair não queria mais falar sobre o
que eu pensava não queria sugerir nada
em sala de aula e colocaram um outro dia
tive me que a timidez né então cresci
achando que era tímida e nesse período
de crise e descobri que também tinha
outro nome além de racismo era time
deles era silenciamento no final do
ensino médio descobrir que estava sendo
silenciado o tempo todo e que bom que a
ficha caiu e por conta desse contexto é
começar a pensar o que me motivava a
fazer coisas e temáticas que me faz
vibrar toda vez que eu falasse
toda vez que o que as pessoas realmente
param para escutar o que realmente é
útil para alguém e se realmente esse
realmente faz sentido o que eu poderia
vir falar e nesse meio termo meio tempo
de transição escola faculdade
encontrei uma causa chamada educação em
direitos humanos
tá pode parecer à primeira vista pode
parecer à primeira vista que geralmente
eu acho algo muito impossível de
acontecer e se colocado em prática
principalmente quando se fala em
direitos humanos que a primeira coisa
que a gente ouve que direitos humanos e
direito de bandido então a gente não
pode trabalhar com isso a defender
bandido eu falei é também não fica de
direitos humanos direitos de todos e
todas e nesse processo de tentar
entender o direito humano à comunicação
a educação como direito humano e o
direito humano também como algo que pode
ser violado com a comunicação surgiu um
desabafo social surgiu a rede social
muito só que antes eram pra ver se faz
sentido ou se é muito tópico ou se
estamos pisando no chão eu gostaria que
vocês respondem a algumas questões para
ver se não tô louca pra ver se eu não
estou louca é todo mundo que tem
facebook
vamos levantar uma quinta facebook
também imaginaria isso né
quem aqui nas eleições de 2014
presidenciais se estressou em algum
momento bloqueou screen ou excluir
alguma pessoa da rede pode tudo
devagarzinho mas sob elas costumam ser
pronto é o que é que já perdeu a
paciência feio mesmo com alguém de fora
não fala mais com aquela pessoa como
aquela pizza pronta como é que aquela
pessoa pensa assim meu deus aquela coisa
que a gente nunca imagina que nosso
amigo pode pensar daquele jeito é ficar
e pronto tudo bem é só para mostrar que
mesmo a gente pensando em coletivo
temos as mesmas sensações é raiva é amor
entendeu não e aí é muito difícil ter
paciência nas redes sociais a gente sabe
disso
é muito difícil ter paciência nas redes
sociais e acabamos excluindo bloqueando
uma pessoa e de certa forma anulando a
existência do outro pelo simples fato da
gente concordar
isso é um exercício diário não é fácil
exige muita paciência acredita eu tenha
exercitado essa paciência por muito
tempo e não fugindo muito de rede social
e tentando fazer com que a mesma rede
que é o facebook que a maioria tem
pudesse ser um lugar de diálogo mas
também foi muito difícil porque
prostituição nas frases que eu vou falar
agora pra vc faz sentido eu não ter
colocado isso tentado isso na rede
social facebook é é a transição
estou num momento muito importante da
minha vida e estou procurando
referências negras espero que aqui eu
posso encontrar eu sou branca e acabei
de descobrir meu privilégio eu posso
aprender com vocês
ou então se eu falar sobre o meu país
será que você chegado os brasileiros
negros irão me abraçar e irão entender o
então professor de geografia professor
de geografia e história exposta te
ajudar é geografia né para o enem está
aí
e pra finalizar é eu não concordo com
você mas eu entendo que você está
falando e eu posso sugerir alguns t
alguns vídeos e depois a gente volta a
conversar
pronto essas frases não foram ditas no
facebook
até porque sete discutir esse privilégio
seria uma polêmica a gente pedisse ajuda
pra só pessoas negras seria uma polêmica
também então resolvemos criar um
conjunto que a rede social de
aprendizagem colaborativa é tentar
trazer essas questões que a gente sabe
que vai se expressar em outra rede
social e tentar dialogar e tentar
conectar pessoas pessoas diferentes de
classes sociais diferentes gêneros
diferentes raças diferentes mas que
encontraram na rede social muito um
denominador comum para poder trocar
experiências trocar o que sabe tudo isso
que vocês vão fazer hoje na dinâmica
inclusive e isso acontece na sua
plataforma parecia utopia né mas é muito
real o mundo surgiu no dia 10 de
dezembro porque é o dia internacional
dos direitos humanos e por mais que a
idéia inicial tenha sido criar uma rede
com foco em participação política
direitos humanos em forma geral é
importante deixar escurecido que pelo
nome talvez tenha atraído mais pessoas
negras e distribuir 3 mil usuários 82
por cento são mulheres negras e talvez
isso reforça duas coisas básicas
é a sensação de comunidade de sonoridade
mesmo e de identificação entre as
mulheres negras e acredito também que as
pessoas que acessaram estão acessando
álbum tu começar a entender aquela
diferença que eu disse no início que
entre o time de silenciamento do escuro
disco é descobrir o que estavam ser
silenciado e conseguiram falar por muito
tempo que não estava conseguindo
conseguiu falar na rede social
então eu compreendo muito quando a
maioria na rede social hoje são mulheres
negras mas calma minha gente que como eu
disse no início o foco não era esse mas
foi se tornando o quilombo digital então
todas as pessoas podem entrar
negros e não negros porque a ideia troca
é o que você tem de melhor para doar o
mundo né gente sempre pergunta sim é
quais são os jovens que o mundo precisa
conhecer porque aquele livro
extraordinário disse que toda pessoa
merece ser aplaudida de pé porque todo
mundo ganhou o mundo então a gente tem
que exercitar isso nessa em uma única
plataforma reunindo todas as pessoas e
mais do que digamos 41 82% de mulheres
negras ea única plataforma se conectando
trocando cada um de um lugar e é muito
legal quando você vai para o país e tem
todo o pessoal do méxico onde não
conheço a rede social a pessoa está
fazendo parte então tá virando algo da
américa latina e isso é muito
gratificante e orgulhoso pra todo mundo
que faz parte que sua construção e mais
do que ser uma forma de protesto
o álbum mostra a forma de resistência e
é mais do que nós contra eles porque
algum significa eu sou porque nós somos
gente tem que estar o tempo todo ea
melhora é o melhor de tudo o que eu
estava pensando assim um louco que o
melhor que conseguimos com a melhor
tecnologia é a maior ferramenta de todos
os tempos
fazer isso que foi o diálogo e obrigado
de verdade